wenn olaf scholz sich zum ukraine kriege
äußert spitzen millionen deutsche und
europäer die ohren preis der
bundeskanzler nun zügig nach kiew lässt
er in kürze schwere waffen ausliefern
weiß er seine verteidigungsministerin in
die schranken doch antworten gibt es auf
diese drängende fragen so gut wie keine
[Musik]
kanzler trotzig so gibt sich olaf scholz
in den vergangenen tagen ein möglicher
grund auf so viele forderungen von außen
geht in der kanzler- einfach nicht ein
wirkt fast so als ignoriere er die
stimmen ganz bewusst aber der reihe nach
die geforderte ukraine reisen diese
umarmung hätte ihm gehören können so
sorgte der polnische staatschef du dat
anhalt für diese große geste ein großes
bild für die welt immerhin
aussenministerin annalena baerbock
reiste nach butter und traf selensky
kauf oppositionsführer friedrich merz
sah sich das schrecken des krieges
persönlich an das fernbleiben des
kanzlers für viele unerklärlich
mittlerweile hat der kanzler alle
möglichen chancen einer reise verpasst
er rechtfertigt seine nicht reise so es
muss bei einem besuch vor ort darauf
ankommen dass konkret etwas
vorangebracht wird und darf nicht nur
ein fototermin sein ich werde mich nicht
einreihen in eine gruppe von leuten die
für ein kurzes rein und raus mit einem
fototermin was machen sondern wenn dann
geht es immer um ganz konkrete dinge
konkrete dinge gutes stichwort reden wir
über die waffenlieferungen hier der
vergleich
die ukraine so listet sie auf braucht
vor allem schwere waffen so etwas wie
panzerhaubitzen oder weitere gepanzerte
fahrzeuge
rechts die deutsche export liste vom 21
april wir sehen keine panzer keine
haubitzen und keine weiteren fahrzeuge
brisant das deutsche rüstungsunternehmen
rheinmetall beantragte einen tag später
die lieferung von 100 marder panzern
keine reaktion der bundesregierung des
kanzlers
zusätzlich sagt die regierung ganz
offiziell sie könne keine martha panzer
aus bundeswehrbeständen liefern auch das
stimmt nicht laut internen papier
während 32 panzer lieferbar
kanzler trotzig trotzt aber nicht nur
beim thema ukraine reise und
waffenlieferungen auch
verteidigungsministerin christine
lambrecht steht seit wochen massiv in
der kritik leistet sich einen patzer
nach dem anderen und was tut olaf scholz
erhält an ihr fest und stemmt sich auch
hier scheinbar ganz bewusst gegen die
breite öffentliche meinung mal sehen wie
lange kanzler trotz sich noch an seinem
kurs festhalten kann
ja und diese frage geben wir gleich
weiter an unserem bild politik chef jan
schäfer der hier bei uns im studio ist
ja wie lange kann olaf scholz noch so
weitermachen also mit blick auf die
umfragewerte seiner spd kann er
eigentlich so nicht weitermachen und
wenn er ins ausland hört und das tut er
natürlich auch sehr viel dann kann er so
eigentlich auch nicht weitermachen die
kritik und die enttäuschung im ausland
über den deutschen kurs über diesen
brems kurs und wir haben es ja auch
gerade gehört kanzler trotzig die nimmt
eigentlich fast täglich zu und in dem
beitrag ist ja gerade auch ganz richtig
gesagt worden dass die ukraine mehr oder
weniger seit über einem monat auf diese
marder panzer warte bzw auf die freigabe
weil rheinmetall beantragt hat ende
april bis zu 100 marder panzer liefern
zu können in die ukraine dieser antrag
der ist bisher nicht beschieden der
liegt also auch bei olaf scholz und der
kanzler tut eigentlich nichts um auch
nicht nur der ukraine aber auch den
restlichen westen zu dokumentieren wir
sind eine führungsmacht deutschlands
eine führungsmacht und wir engagieren
uns ganz aktiv in dieser
auseinandersetzung in diesem krieg gegen
russland die opposition die gewinnt den
eindruck sagt sie ganz klar dass olaf
scholz gar nicht mehr weh dass die
ukraine den krieg gewinnt es gibt einige
unionspolitiker die mittlerweile in
zweifel ziehen ob olaf scholz eigentlich
wirklich einen sieg der ukraine möchte
wir erinnern uns an seine
regierungserklärung vom vergangenen
donnerstag
auch da sagte olaf scholz nicht dass es
darum geht dass die ukraine gewinnt
sondern dass die ukraine besteht und
wenn man mit militärexperten
beispielsweise spricht aber auch mit
experten im bundestag dann sagen die
ganz klar es kann eigentlich in dieser
auseinandersetzung mit russland nur noch
um einen ganz klaren sieg der ukraine
gehen und nicht mehr darum dass
möglichst russland auch gesichtswahrend
aus dieser aus diesem konflikt heraus
kommen nein es geht darum wirklich
militärisch russland in der ukraine zu
besiegen was bedeutet das für die
deutsche außenwirkung die ist schlecht
darüber haben wir gerade schon
gesprochen es gibt immer wieder und
immer lauter werdende kritik auch an
deutschland nicht an der aus ministerin
die fährt er ja einen sehr klaren kurs
aber vor am bundeskanzler und an seiner
verteidigungsministerin und wenn man
sich überlegt das ist eigentlich schon
vor vier wochen hätte ein ok grünes
licht geben können für die lieferung von
marder panzern panzer in die ukraine
dann muss man sagen dann wird er doch
sehr sehr stark auf die bremse gedrückt
dann ist das ganz land eigentlich gar
kein führerstand in dem sinne dass man
sagt hier wird auch ein land richtig
geführt sondern ist es eigentlich mehr
ein schneckenhaus bei dem auf der bremse
gestanden wird dass ihr
verteidigungsministerin angesprochen was
glaubst du wie lange kann scholz
überhaupt noch an ihr festhalten wir
wissen aus dem umfeld des bundeskanzlers
dass er eigentlich kein großes interesse
hat seine verteidigungs ministerin zu
entlassen weil das wie eine persönliche
auch schmerzhafte niederlage für ihn
wirken könnte das würde ist natürlich
auch das ist richtig aber die abwägung
muss auf der anderen seite auch sein wie
lange kann sich dieses land diese
bundesverteidigungsministerium noch
leisten mein eindruck ist es fehlt nicht
mehr vielen pannen und peinlichkeiten
bei frau lamprecht und dann wird scholz
gezwungen seien sie aus dem amt zu
entfernen noch einmal zusammenfassend
was fordert die opposition jetzt auch
weil wir haben ja schon oft jetzt über
stimmen aus der cdu unter anderem über
die gesprochen was wird dort gefordert
also cdu chef friedrich merz hat es ja
mehrmals betont und sagt ganz klar es
kann nicht sein dass deutschland seit
beispielsweise in der april auch gar
keine schweren waffen mehr geliefert hat
an die ukraine es gibt jetzt ja die
lieferung von ein paar marder panzern
die dann im juli stattfinden wird als
zweites fordert die union dass frau
lamprecht die verteidigungsministerin
entlassen wird und natürlich gibt es die
forderung auch die friedrich merz
erhoben hat olaf scholz herr
bundeskanzler fahren sie in die ukraine
jetzt ist ein afrika das ist sicherlich
auch eine wichtige reise aber man hat
auch da wieder der eindruck kanzler
trotzig in die ukraine in die ukraine in
die ukraine fahre ich nicht aber ich
fahre nach afrika und das gleiche mist
dann auch bei den waffen ich lieber
keine schweren waffen ich lieber keine
schweren waffen weil man es ihm offenbar
immer wieder gesagt hat dass das tun
soll also ein bisschen trotzig wie ein
kind und bei frau lambrecht das ähnlich
es gibt immer wieder die forderung auch
jetzt natürlich erhoben von der
opposition dass frau lampe lassen werden
soll und man hat fast den eindruck der
kanzler stampft mit dem fuß auf und
sagten nein ich entlasse sie nicht wann
wird es einen kurswechsel geben bei
kanzler trotz weg wenn es soweit ist
dann erfahren sie das natürlich hier
vielen herzlichen eigentlich ein schäfer
für deinen besuch hier bei uns im studio